oh after what happened in 2003  i  how how do you even like  step on the field for game four i mean  how how did anyone kind of motivate the  the clubhouse i mean who was there to  kind of yeah who's giving the speech in  the clubhouse well it was tough but  kevin millar stepped up and  nobody wanted to start taking their kids  to school  kevin millar brought out  shots of jack daniels and we had nothing  to lose and so we went out there and we  just are you seeing before the game  before the game before game four yeah  you know a couple of shots  and then in the world series game one  game two game three game four come on  everyone's doing shots to jaden  loose was that the magic juice i mean it  was that year